so when you look where we are today uh
it feels like the
fed is the most important person in the
market and kind of their monetary policy
decisions some of the fiscal policy
decisions that are being made as well
how do you kind of create a framework to
evaluate what's happening uh
and what the impact of that will be in
the future is there a specific framework
that you use
uh the closest thing after a framework
is the concept of the long-term debt
cycle popularized by ray dalio
uh and so that's the idea that you know
we go through these five to ten year
business cycles
uh with with rising debt uh and you know
you have a recession and then you you go
into the next cycle
but if you string a bunch of those
together what we've actually seen is
that each cycle doesn't reset to the
previous one
uh in terms of debt or interest rates
and so what do you get is higher and
higher debt as a percentage of gdp over
time
and you get lower lower interest rates
and that that happens for decades
until interest rates run into roughly
zero or in some cases mildly negative
uh and so they run out of that policy
room and have to pull in other types of
tools
and so the last time we were in this
type of environment in most developed
countries was actually back in the 1940s
uh and so you know we have a lot of
analogs to that time obviously with
different technology
and things like that so that's that's
actually my main probably
a model framework uh but then you know
more tactically i'm just kind of looking
at
what are the bottlenecks in the system
that would force say policymakers to do
something and so because we're at the
end of a long-term debt cycle
we're in a very macro heavy environment
and so some of the things that people
expected over the past
say 30 40 years are behaving very
differently in this environment
that's how i approach it got it and i
think that you and i see very eye-to-eye
in terms of a lot of what's going on but
uh for those that are watching at home
just how do you think of your portfolio
today so like
is there an allocation that you kind of
are targeting or if somebody
said to you like where you invested at
the moment just so they have that
perspective of kind of how you're you're
tactically actually playing in the
market
i have kind of like an all-weather
approach right i remain somewhat
diversified
uh however i tilt towards areas that i
think are
you know likely to have a much stronger
performance over say a a five-year
period
uh and so that includes for me i'm a
pretty equity focused so i include a lot
of individual equities uh and then i
have some other
hedges or asymmetric bets uh on the side
and of course ever since early 2020 i've
been pretty big into bitcoin as well
uh and so for me it's you know my my
portfolio is mostly underweight
you know the the bond side for example
and pretty heavy into equities
digital at uh uh some commodity
exposures
uh and that that's where a lot of my
focus is uh over the past
few years one of the things that i keep
uh kind of coming back to is this idea
that
the economy seems to uh still be
recovering from
uh kovid and the economic downturn that
occurred
in response to that uh and there's been
all this fiscal monetary stimulus
and a couple of weeks ago we saw the
nasdaq and smp hit an all-time high
uh at the time the same day that the
fed's balance sheet hit an all-time high
we today saw that nasdaq hit another
all-time high and it almost feels like
it's like a weekly occurrence now that
asset prices just continue to go higher
and higher
yes there's some drawbacks here and
there but for the most part we're just
trending in one direction
how much of this is a game where whether
it's the fed or politicians on the
physical side like they just can't stop
and so we're just going to continue to
see this
happen over the coming months versus you
think that actually the music will stop
at some point
and and we'll see some different
activities from both of those groups
uh so a lot of it is the currency going
down uh just as much as the assets going
up
but you know we see for example there
are certain balances in the system
uh and so in the united states case uh
you know we we run very large
uh trade deficits uh with the rest of
the world
uh and then they take those dollars and
they used to reinvest was back into
treasuries
uh and you know to a greater extent
they've been investing elsewhere
but they actually have cycling a lot of
that back into u.s equities now
and so you know basically uh switzerland
for example will buy apple stock
uh in their swiss national bank uh and
so that that's kind of a policy we've
been seeing both from
uh public pools of capital and private
pools of capital overseas
and so this feedback loop uh is pretty
persistent
uh but every couple decades that whole
kind of feedback
loop can unwind uh and so you know i
think it's it's getting
pretty heated at this current time and i
think some of the things to watch for
potential reversal
would be say changes regulation that
maybe go after corporate taxes
or that uh you know basically basically
what we've seen over the past few
decades is arbitrage where
productivity's gone up a lot but wages
have not and that's because of
automation technology
as well as offshoring and so that gap
between productivity
and flat wages has mainly gone to the
corporations
uh and so we've had you know roughly you
know four decades of that it really
accelerated
uh in the 90s and so that loop is
starting to get kind of
pushed back from pop you know populism
uh and some policymakers
and so i you know i still think that has
a little bit more to go but i do think
that that eventually is going to
probably that pendulum is probably going
to start moving back the other direction
where policymakers i guess favor
corporations a little bit less than they
have over the past few decades